the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of aun's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
season 8 video in this video you're
going to see there was another Game of
Thrones actor who recently revealed how
they honestly feel about the ending of
the show
as you all know Game of Thrones had one
of the most divisive endings in
television history and ever since the
show went off the air many of its actors
have since revealed how they really felt
about the show's final season in fact
I've already discussed what many of the
actors had to say in some of my recent
videos well in this new video you're
going to find out what Amelia thinks of
Game of Thrones final season now that
it's been over four years since it ended
like I have stated in my other videos
you're going to start to see a lot more
honesty out of the Game of Thrones
actors as we get further and further
away from its last episode they won't be
as afraid to speak out against David and
Dan's writing as the years go by now
during an exclusive new interview Amelia
Clark gives more insight into what she
actually thought about how Game of
Thrones ended let's have a look at the
article so you know exactly what I mean
fandom wire says Amelia is still Furious
about kid Harrington getting away with
one unforgivable scene that killed Game
of Thrones not only that but she also
admits to feeling the same way most the
fans have since the show's final season
you'll see what I mean very shortly fans
have embraced each and every title
aelia's Game of Thrones character
Daenerys held throughout the several
seasons the show ran but the one she
dawned in the very last season did not
sit right with many although the
internet stays divided half the time it
unanimously agreed that the last season
of one of the most acclaimed HBO
television shows did not serve Justice
to the Beloved characters so much so
that despite being a staunch defender of
the show
over time the Mother of Dragons herself
also came to acknowledge that the ending
was not the one she'd imagined during
her new interview with the times the
actress complained about all the things
that noded her about the ending
including Jon Snow getting away with
literal murder Amelia who we also know
as the one and only daera stargaryen on
the show also did not fully digest the
fate of her character although the
actress voiced her strong support
immediately after the release of the
most hype season as time goes by she
confessed she as well was left
dissatisfied like millions of the fans
across the globe the ending of the show
had several issues the fans had a
problem with however the one that stood
out the most in agreement among its
viewers was daenerys's sudden and out of
character actions at the very end this
in turn culminated in her shocking death
at the hands of Jon Snow now during this
new interview with the times she stated
yeah I felt for her I really felt for
her in I was annoyed that Jon Snow
didn't have to deal with something he
got away with murder literally instead
of facing execution for what he'd done
he received a sentence to join the
Nights Watch by bran which infuriated
Amelia and rightfully so although I do
understand what Amelia means by Jon Snow
not facing execution it wasn't like he
got to walk away freely either having to
live the rest of your life out Beyond
the Wall in the frozen tundra isn't
exactly something anyone would wish for
although Jon did not seem very upset by
that sentence I wonder if Amilia thinks
daera should have lived at the end of
the show after everything she had done
to King's Landing and its residence now
I know she was very upset with how David
and Dan ended her story but I wonder if
she thinks Daenerys did the right thing
by burning everyone in the city I'm not
sure if I ever heard her discuss that
yet now let's see what else she had to
say in addition to her own
disappointment with the fate of her
character on the show the actress also
openly voiced her concerns about the
ending of the show confessing that the
finale might not resonate with its
millions of of devoted fans in that same
interview she stated I knew how I felt
about the ending when I first read it
and I tried at every turn to not
consider too much of what other people
might say but I always did consider what
the fans might think because we did it
for them and they were the ones who made
us successful so it's just polite isn't
it now it's what she actually says next
that I find very interesting because
I've never heard her say this before
adding to this she also acknowledged
that the show could have taken its sweet
time to roll out the curtains rather
than taking the rushed approach that
hurt them in the end she said it was all
about the set pieces I think The
Sensational nature of the show was
possibly given a huge amount of airtime
because that's what makes sense we could
have spun it out for a little longer
well we can now add Amelia to the ever
growing list of Game of Thrones actors
who now feel the show was ended much too
soon not only did she dislike daenerys's
ending but now she finally admits the
entire show as a whole should not have
ended when it did it's actually kind of
sad to to know Amelia has finally come
to the realization that David and Dan
shifted their focus from The Amazing
characters to the show's massive sets
and locations unfortunately the show
that once had some of the greatest
writing I'd ever seen eventually
devolved into nothing but empty or
shallow spectacle like I've said before
this will not be the last time we hear
the actor say something like this most
of them were not ready to say things
like this immediately after the show
ended because they themselves were ready
to work on something else not only that
but some of them were most likely afraid
to say anything out of fear of losing
any future work well now a lot of them
no longer feel the same way they once
did now that they've had several years
to reflect on what actually happened
during that final season of the show
hopefully they now realize that all of
the fans still stand with them why is it
ending uh I don't know ask David and Dan
when they come
through um we could have gone to 11 12
13 Seasons but uh they I guess they
wanted a life uh you wanted it to keep
going well it it you know if you've read
my
novels you you know there was enough
material for for more seasons they made
certain cuts um but but that's fine we
have five other shows five prequels in
development that are based on other
periods in the history of Westeros some
of them just 100 years before Game of
Thrones some of them 5,000 years before
Game of Thrones have you shot your final
scene yet and are you happy with how
things ended
yeah she didn't say yes you didn't
say best season
ever beston what was it like shooting
those final scenes though and you knew
it was Final so sad so sad but then
everyone gets ready for the emotion and
everyone there being like Oh it's going
to be the lot how many more takes are we
going to we're just going to and then it
kind of wears off and every like okay
bye up you're like oh this is the last
one this is the last scene and then
there like four takes in you're like oh
this okay the momentum's dropped a
little bit now but that happened on on
like what was supposed to be my last day
I finished and then they were like oh
but you need a pick we've got a pick up
of you um in a month's time and I was
like oh okay see you in a
[Music]
month